[Music]
good morning gamers
good morning donkey what is this
huh what are you doing get out of here
shoosh apparently cats don't like water
but if
they don't like water why is he staying
in the water huh
you're evil i'm on to you you can't meow
your
way out of this one good morning
is he sleeping what is he doing are you
okay
what is he is he stuck i think he's
stuck
cool anyway bunkie i know you're donkey
i've been afk this whole night i mean
because i wanted to check out just how
efficient the automatic farms are
i love them they're so pretty
[Music]
why do they make bread stop making bread
i thought this guy oh i put beetroot
there
oh i need to change that oh my gosh
i don't whoa how did i do that bonky
what are you doing i need your help
i gotta give them props they're very
efficient how did i do that
holding shift and double clicking a
stack moves all items
oh no that's that's just a stack
so i pick one hold shift and then double
click oh my
oh yes amazing
i'm learning so much about minecraft
there we go uh yeah yeah i don't know
what i'm gonna do with this much carrots
or potatoes and oh my god is this gonna
get more and more what am i
uh automatic farm too powerful
uh but hey i got it at least you okay
all right great i also made a
an automatic wolf farm it was very
simple
so i took the liberty and i don't know
what it is i feel like i talked to some
people about automatic farms
and they just don't care to some people
is like oh
yeah automatic farms to me
having someone do work for you just is
very satisfying
i know that sounds weird like computers
wait did you say something
no all right it's just satisfying it's
so satisfying it's like if you ever
watch a 3d printer it's like oh my god
it's so nifty i just like watching it
work
i i think it's from when i used to to uh
cheat
playing tibia and we would have bots and
then instead of just playing yourself
i would just watch the bot i'm like dude
he's so good
he's totally killing it right okay
anyway uh
learning a lot about minecraft i know
probably most of you don't care but
i asked what the best armor is right and
i think i understand now
everyone says different which is kind of
annoying so it's kind of hard to
understand fully
and i'm sure people are going to say no
you're wrong but as far as i understand
the best way to go
is just to put protection on everything
because protection gives you
all the different enchantments i want to
test this out
so basically if you put fire protection
on one thing
it gives you four fire protection or
something like that but then if you
add another fire protection another
armor it only gives you
let's say you'd think it would be four
plus four is eight but it's like
maybe seven or or less so the more you
have
the same one the less it adds i don't
know the exact numbers but that i
understand
so i thought okay so then i should just
have one
different type of enchantment on each
like one has protection or two and then
one fire protection and one blast
protection
apparently that's not correct and
protection gives you
a little bit of feather falling as well
i want to test this out
i want to do my own experiments because
i can't trust anyone
and if it goes wrong it goes wrong
this looks so funny it's so weird seeing
gas
in the over world and also i realized
that some people
might think something is best for
survival mode but i'm playing on
hardcore so it's different right
i don't think it's cheating to test
stuff out in a different world
right right okay
uh let's try falling from 70 blocks
i'm not gonna die gamers i'm not gonna
die
oh god i'm gonna die all right maybe
that's a little high
okay what is this 35 blocks that's
pretty high
so this is with protection how much
damage do i take
it's a three and a half stars okay this
is becoming way too nerdy
how much damage do i then take without
protection on my feet
whoa that's a lot more
holy okay this is with feather
falling and protection
what oh i didn't put them on
okay don't you feel relieved you do
something that doesn't make sense and
then you realize oh you're just an idiot
all right here we go yeah that's even
less
my god how high can i fall without dying
i'm sure someone's done a video on this
i i just prefer doing it myself because
then i know for sure
there's different versions as well right
all right 45 blocks
this is a fall jump dude what
op if i don't even take half damage on
should i be able to jump from 90 then no
no there's no way 90 blocks
oh god here we go
what
pretty damn good it looks like
protection so far is the way to go
okay this is protection on everything
how does that hold up against a creeper
blast
[Music]
i can still survive a creeper blast okay
what if i have blast protection on my
legs or something
okay let's try on with blast protection
a lot less does anyone care
i don't know i care because i'm not
going to die
okay i'm curious how that holds up on
the same jump because we could
we could survive this jump with all
protection right
i don't think we can now but let's check
it out
where do i jump here
you still can this is probably the setup
to go
is there any noticeable difference if i
have golden legs and fire protection
that is way slower i think i found i
found out the ultimate combo guys
for hardcore according to me the
ultimate combo
is protection on everything except blast
protection on your leggies
and then once you go in the nether you
swap out with fire protection on your
leggies
is there any difference if you have
netherite with
falling damage let's test it out
i should be on two health it's the same
interesting
cool no one cares this means i've done
this all wrong
it's all right this is still pretty good
at least the netherride is
correctly placed let's uh try strip
mining netherright and see how fast we
can find it
where's bonkey where he is my man
oh i just fed you a golden carrot didn't
i
also the amount of comments telling me
you can't breed a horse
if you have something in your offhand
you don't need to feed them wheat
i don't know why i always thought they
just made sense to me that you would
give them something
all right maybe i'm just really nice it
would have saved me a lot of hassle in
early gameplay
all right let's go i'm ready
shut up i don't know if it's a la britta
i bless you with a golden carrot
thank you you want to accept the gift
excellent all right i have five
resistance potions
so the best should be 15 and 16 so here
oh god i never done this this sounds
like a bad idea
but that's a good idea so let's do two
steps same way and then let's hit
it whoa
damn that's a bigger explosion than i
thought okay
i think i'm gonna drink the fire potion
just while doing this insane stuff
i should have put it deeper oh this is
fun
oh look at that well well well
this is a nightmare to look at yeah
definitely worth using the fire potion
all right come to papi
nice
[Laughter]
whoa oh it's so beautiful you just see
it right away
come to poppy jesus christ
[Music]
okay well if there is any other right in
there i'm not going to find it
[Music]
don't try this at home kids actually you
should it's really fun
ah am i beautiful
all right so we already got four let's
keep going
oh my beautiful oh my god it's in the
lava
there we go i am the ruler of the lava
yes ah my beautiful reveals itself
oh they don't disappear in lava sweet
that makes sense
i'm so scared i'm gonna click on the bed
by accident oh
all right quick scan
ah yes my pretty we used to die from
sleeping in the nether
now we roll the bench of the nether okay
new system
i'm gonna blow it three in one
now the right nether right now the right
no
okay i don't have fire another right now
they're right in there right no
all right another right now the right no
it's my face filter work
yeah it looks terrifying it's so hard to
see in the nether
oh no did i blow up my whole hub not the
wall
oh it made it oops sorry guys
i'm actually not sure i mean i'm sure
i'm getting faster as i'm going but i'm
not sure if it is
fast yeah it must be faster
[Music]
all right number eight
oh hollow three stacks all right i'll
take it
it just never stops getting satisfying
three baby come to me
almost didn't see you there oh
come come come alright so there's the
damage
28 degrees i would say that took me pro
i don't know how
sime knows how long that took me i i
definitely got quicker in the end
but yeah you could probably average one
per minute but i don't think that's what
i did
either way it's more debris than i've
ever had so i'm very satisfied that's
amazing
and it's way more fun than just digging
hey guys how's it going i'm rich dude
so that leaves us with seven
not as exciting as i hope but
nice i can do my sword
oh i could do my shovel i'll get
even my axe oh my god i'm gonna be fully
stacked i have enough
fully stacked near the right alright i'm
not yet but i will
[Laughter]
well i guess it's time to melt some
glass again
it's time to get some sand bonkey
oh sorry monkey oh my god this is where
the ravine is isn't it
this feels dumb let's not go there
whoa all right we're good
so apparently you can make like a
smelting system where you just dump
everything into a chest
i will make that i definitely will make
that
but for now the god church will lit up
like he's never done before
you're gonna be beautiful
sure why not can't even reach
ah ah maximum
god church one day the whole church will
burn
and it will be beautiful okay so here's
another nifty thing you guys told me
if i make a trade and then just press
space
it will keep appearing oh my god that's
so much easier thank you guys
so yeah make a trade hold space
or click space oh my god yes all right
so i can heal my shovel
by doing this i forgot about that nice
fully healed
sweet i'll do the same with my axe so i
need protection
who has
no
i should not be holding an axe at least
he didn't die
i'm so sorry
don't tell anyone i hate you
yes oh i got it
sick
[Music]
ah yes
oh all the best enchantments
i mean i could get like death strider
and stuff like that but to protect
myself
nothing's going to hurt me if only i
could put it on you donkey
i would put it on you in a heartbeat but
since i can't
i guess i will have them damn that feels
good
all right gamers we made some stoics we
made some levels and we made some
goddamn nether armor
smash like for the series to epically
continue i see you guys in the next one
[Music]
i'm all brofist i'm mine all the time i
can't find what i want